[Music]
foreign
hi my name is Andrew Bray and I'm an
associate teaching professor in
statistics at UC Berkeley I'd like to
tell you my top three reasons why you
should take the introduction to quarter
workshop at positcoms
number one feel the flexibility one of
the things I love about quarto is how
flexible it is offering a document
always feels the same I'm typing into a
simple text file but when I go to render
it I could make a PDF file or Word
document or an HTML file or a slide
presentation what's more if there's code
in that document it could be R code or
shiny or python or Julia
in this Workshop you'll get to feel that
flexibility at the end of the day you'll
produce a broad range of polished
documents you'll emerge with a big
picture view of everything that's
possible with quarto reason number two a
guide through the docs
if you've started tinkering around with
quarto you've probably discovered that
there's extensive documentation
available at quarto.org but if you're
just getting started this can be pretty
overwhelming
in this Workshop you're getting a
curated guide through the vast
functionality of carto in the morning
we'll start off with a single static
document and then we'll add
functionality bit by bit until we have
something quite sophisticated
in the afternoon we'll shift our Focus
to putting together a beautiful slide
presentation
reason number three live coding
something that many of the workshops at
positive comp share is the practice of
live coding this means that in addition
to using slides I'll be projecting my
Studio's session so you can see me code
up a crypto document live
this is helpful because in addition to
getting to see the syntax you're also
getting to see the workflow of authoring
the cuarto document and when errors pop
up because they will pop up you'll get
to see somebody else's approach to
getting unstuck so if you're ready to
dive into everything you can do with
carto please join us at the workshop in
Chicago we hope to see you there
foreign